der comedian
seit 1955 rollt der weltberühmte
transkontinentale passagierzug von via
rail quer durch kanada
vor kurzem überholt und modernisiert ist
er heute besser denn je und seine route
ist voller aufregender geschichte
[Musik]
als die gleise verlegt worden sind viele
arbeiter gestorben
ich liebe zu sie verbluten menschen
miteinander dieser zug hat das land
geprägt
der canadian hält im hauptbahnhof von
vancouver bald beginnt wilsons großes
abenteuer
doch bevor der zug zurück an die
ostküste fährt bedarf es vieler
fleißiger hände
besser
es ist voller insekten
und akribischer techniker
der motor der lokomotive wird gewartet
[Musik]
und die stahlräder werden überprüft ist
eine stelle schadhaft oder abgenutzt
wird sie abgeschliffen
bevor das canada abenteuer beginnt
besucht wilson den wohl größten fan des
zuges
jason hat sogar einen original waggon in
seinem haus
unglaublich
mit richtigen fahrgeräuschen
ein eisenbahnwaggon der im keller steht
unglaublich das ist dein ballon von 1980
wir haben die fenster und türen entfernt
viel von dem was sie hier sehen ist aus
diesem wetter was macht den canadiens so
legendär
der caddy entsteht für kanada wer damit
unterwegs ist lernt das ganze land
kennen
im medien macht man eine zeitreise der
zug wurde 1955 eingeführt
er wurde 1981 1990 und verkürzung
überhaupt heute ist es nach dem neuesten
stand der technik aber trotzdem ein
stück geschichte beim fans aus aller
welt fahren mit dem canadian diese fahrt
vergisst man nie
am hauptbahnhof in vancouver rückt die
abfahrten her
18 uhr 16 geht's los die lokführer
brennen deren und leslie redford
besprechen ein letztes wichtiges detail
wann und wo sie das gleis wechseln
müssen um sicher aus dem bahnhof zu
kommen
die züge fahren hier unter allem wie ein
puzzle wir müssen viele gleise queren
die gleise sind privatisiert die weichen
gehören unterschiedlichen
eisenbahngesellschaften
um von einem gleis aus als andere zu
kommen brauchen die fahrer von
personenzügen mehrere freigaben
wenn wir ohne freigabe fahren sind wir
unseren job los und
es könnten unfälle passieren beim
planen der route werden die lokführer
rund um die uhr von der leitstelle in
montreal unterstützt
hat nicolas ilias alle züge von via rail
canada habe die auf ihrer reise vier
zeitzonen passieren
das ist unser streckennetz hier sehen
wir ob zwei züge im gleichen gebiet
fahren können oder nicht
nicolas es viel gas ist da wenn's brennt
wenn das telefon klingelt
jeder hält die luft an weil alles
mögliche passiert sein kann
technische oder mechanische probleme
ein todesfall anbau hat oder der zug ist
entgleist
gut zu wissen dass die mitarbeiter in
montreal alles im blick haben
der comedien lässt vancouver hinter sich
und fährt ostwärts auf den 4500
kilometern spürt man seine enorme
leistung
er fährt durchs gebirge durch mehrere
tunnel und über 670 brücken er muss
einen eine million hektar großen sumpf
passieren bevor er an seinem ziel in
toronto ankommt
vor der abfahrt überprüft lokführer
redford noch einmal die bremsen und alle
signaltöne
[Musik]
das warnsystem im cockpit registriert
wenn der lokführer abgelenkt ist oder
das bewusstsein verliert werden bremsen
oder steuerung 30 sekunden lang nicht
berührt dann muss der lokführer einen
ganz bestimmten knopf drücken wenn er
nicht gedrückt wird bremst der zug
automatisch bis zum stillstand
diese erfüllt sich ph zwei lokomotive
wiegt fast 120 tonnen so viel wie zwei
leopard 2 panzer
sie ist 18 meter lang und fünf meter
hoch das entspricht einem reihenhaus mit
garten
das abenteuer beginnt
ich bin
sind sie zum ersten mal dabei nein zum
dritten mal es ist toll so zur reise
lieber flucht man vier tage lang im zug
es gibt eine bar
ihre kabine
was ist dann
unters bett in der wand
die sitze klappt man zu sein
ich habe einen generalschlüssel wenn sie
beim essen sind klappe ich die betten
herunter es funktioniert wie bei schrank
bern
bei bedarf ist oben noch ein zweites
bett
sie brauchen wahrscheinlich nur 1
1 reicht mir
[Musik]
da der zug sehr lang ist wurden einige
waggons während der wartungsarbeiten
abgekoppelt
jetzt werden sie wieder angekoppelt
und dann geht's endlich los
[Musik]
der comedian lässt bern kurve hinter
sich und überquert die erste von
insgesamt
670 prüfen
von hier oben sieht man den trans canada
highway
viele güterzüge fahren vorbei manchmal
haben sie mehr als 200 waggons
wenn sie dem canadian auf der
eingleisigen strecke entgegen kommen
musste er auf ein ausweichgleis fahren
wir sind nach sonnenuntergang
losgefahren die hälfte der strecke
fanden acht wenn es hell wäre könnte man
den fraser river sehen
teddy wilson macht sich auf den weg zur
bar um ein paar mitreisende
kennenzulernen
gefällt ihnen die reise
[Applaus]
wir fahren das erste mal nur der reise
wegen mit man lernt kanada aus einer
völlig neuen perspektive kennen
und wie ist das toll
man trifft nette leute und genießt die
reise
100 kilometer nordöstlich von vancouver
warten die ersten tunnel und die ersten
berge jetzt muss die lokomotive zeigen
musikern
sie zieht 18 voll beladene waggons auf
einer länge von einem halben kilometer
hinter sich her
der 16 zylinder dieselmotor hat 3000 ps
so viel wie sechs große reisebusse
der motor treibt einen riesigen
generator an der die vier faktoren
werden den strom versorgt
als diese lokomotiven in den 1980 er
jahren gebaut wurden gehörten sie zu den
stärksten zugmaschinen der welt vor ein
paar jahren haben sich die
verantwortlichen bei brain entschieden
sie zu modernisieren
dank zahlreicher neuerungen ist die lok
heute besser als je zuvor
wir wollten eine moderne flotte die
energie effiziente und leicht zu warten
ist und wir haben auch die leistung der
lokomotive erhöht
wir haben alle beweglichen teile
ausgebaut manche mussten wir wegwerfen
andere haben wir restauriert und wieder
eingebaut
die lok wurde komplett zerlegt die
karosserie wurde repariert der rost
entfernt ein paar größere teile muss mir
austauschen hier hat die lok nicht
einfach nur gewartet das triebwerk ist
heute sogar viel leistungsstärker als
früher
wir mussten platz schaffen um das neue
kühlsystem unterzubringen
mit diesem system spart unsere f40
flotte zehn prozent treibstoff
das geld ist der dieselmotor
der 500 kilowatt starke dieselmotor
liefert energie für alles was die
fahrgäste brauchen licht heizung
klimaanlage küche und toiletten
dadurch verbrennt der hauptmotor
deutlich weniger treibstoff als 4
kurz nach mitternacht hat der canadian
auf einem nebengleis erster
schichtwechsel alles lief glatt 20 war
groß zwei loks keine probleme wir sind
soweit
redford und deren übergeben das steuer
an ihre kollegen der zug wird die
verspätung aufholen
auf ihrem weg durch die berge müssen die
neuen zugführer die zeit im auge
behalten viel glück
es ist nicht leicht im zeitplan zu
bleiben
auf die viel befahrenen eingleisigen
strecke kommen dem canadian viele
güterzüge entgegen
die lokführer müssen aufmerksam sein der
kleinste fehler kann katastrophale
folgen haben
[Musik]
die ersten 12 stunden der reise sind
geschafft bei sonnenaufgang geht es
vorbei an der stadt kamloops british
columbia
auf der anderen seite fließt der nord
thompson
an flüssen entlang zu fahren macht sinn
schließlich
haben sie sich einen weg durch die berge
gegraben
am lidl herz geld fließt der not
thompson durch eine enge schlucht dort
gibt es gefährliche stromschnellen ich
lasse die vorhänge über nacht offen oft
macht man kurze auf und sieht ein
kleines dorf oder einen güterzug vorbei
fahren
und wieder musste kanälen auf die
nebengleise um einem güterzug platz zu
machen
für den verhältnismäßig kurzen canadian
ist es wesentlich einfacher auszuweichen
als für die extrem langen güterzüge
der lokführer muss auf die
unterschiedlichsten signale achten ob
das gleis frei ist aber weiter fahren
kann oder ob eher bremsen und anhalten
muss
wird ein signal übersehen kann es zu
unfällen kommen
2008 übersah ein lokführer im
kalifornischen t12 ein rotes signal
sein zug stieß mit einem güterzug
zusammen 25 menschen starben
die verantwortung eines lokführers ist
nicht zu unterschätzen
jede sekunde rund um die uhr
im canadian fahren nicht nur touristen
mit die bewohner abgelegener dörfer
vivell mount können sogar telefonisch
einen halt beantragen
familie lebt seit generationen in dieser
abgeschiedenen gegend der zug ist ihr
tor zur welt ohne den zu kommen der
nicht zum zahnarzt
lebensnotwendig früher gab es hier keine
straße der zug macht unser dorf mobil
wir sind gerade in robson valley
das ist der mount robson
ist fast 4000 meter hoch an klaren tagen
ist er über 150 kilometer weit zu sehen
was so wunderschön aussieht wirkt auch
enorme gefahren
waldbrände und erdrutsche können ganze
berghänge verwüsten lawinen können
abgehen und die gleise und passierbar
machen
2007 wurde ein streckenabschnitt weiter
südlich unter schneemassen begraben
lawinen tunnel sollen die züge vor
abgängen schützen und spezielle sensoren
warnen vor steinschlag
[Musik]
entlang der gleise sind leitung wenn da
was drauf hält sieht jemand nach dem
rechten
aber bisher ist alles ruhig und der
ausblick könnte nicht schöner sein was
wäre kanada ohne diese strecke es wäre
nicht mehr kanada
die eisenbahn verbindet den osten
kanadas mit dem westen die erste
transkontinentale route zu bauen war ein
hartes stück arbeit
zehn jahre lang wurde die strecke
vermessen und über vier jahre lang
4500 kilometer gleis verlegt
1885 war die strecke fertig
die strecke am fluss entlang zu bauen
war eine echte herausforderung
beim bau der canadian pacific railroad
kommt auf jede meile ein toter arbeiter
und die strecke ist
für die meisten passagiere im kern geht
es nicht darum von a nach b zu kommen
für sie ist der weg das ziel
die landschaft die an den fenstern
vorbei zieht ist ihr
unterhaltungsprogramm
eisenbahnfans lieben es in den
geschichtsträchtigen waggons des
canadian zu setzen jason shaw lebt davon
er baut maßstabgetreu miniaturmodelle
dieser waggons und verkauft sie an
sammler in aller welt
der passagier waggon
ja in den waggon reisen passagiere die
nur einen tag mit fahren viele menschen
denken zugfahren ist wie flugzeug
fliegen das ist es aber ganz und gar
nicht
im zug hat man viel mehr platz der sitz
kann weiter zurück gelehnt werden es ist
zu bequem dass einige passagiere fast
die ganze zeit in diesem wagen bleiben
der schlafwagen genauer gesagt der
männer schlafwagen dort gibt es gruppen
doppel und einzel abteile
welcher waggon ist dass der speise paare
die küche im canadian ist wirklich
ausgezeichnet einer der wenigen züge in
nordamerika in denen das essen frisch
zubereitet wird
imperien werden heute noch dieselben
gerichte wie in den 1950 er jahren
serviert auch der service ist so gut wie
früher
man hat wirklich das gefühl als ob man
in einem schicken restaurant von gomez
sitzt
am ende des waggons ist die küche sie
ist extrem schmal und zweckmäßig alles
hat seinen festen platz
diesen waggon erkennt jeder zug fan
sofort
der skyline waggon mit im glasdach ist
typisch für den canadian hier können
passagiere mehrere dinge tun hat drei
bereiche an einem ende ist die lounge
dort sitzt es sich meiner meinung nach
am bequemsten die sitze sind sehr
gemütlich
in der mitte ist das panorama wacht am
anderen ende des wagens ist das café
dort kann man spiele spielen leute
treffen und etwas essen im café ist
immer etwas los
schlafwagen für die stadt tun
schlafwagen der ersten klasse muss man
tief in die tasche greifen
die couch lässt sich zu einem großen
bett ausziehen jede kabine hat eine
dusche und eine toilette
sie wird übrigens nicht aus glas
entleert larry power vom reinigungsteam
erklärt warum
die toilette darf nicht mehr aufs gleis
entleert werden das ist seit ein paar
jahren verboten zuerst wollte man alles
in einen auffangtank leiten aber in
einem zug gibt es nicht so viel platz
für breite rohre in einem haus
also muss der inhalt der toilette durch
relativ dünne rohre in den tank gesaugt
werden
um zu spülen drückt man einen knopf eine
steuereinheit unter dem wagen aktiviert
dann die vakuumpumpe die sende das
signal spülen all die toilette ein
zug mit 20 waggons hat etwa 130
toiletten ich sage immer sie sind wie
meine kinder ich habe 130 kinder und ich
muss mich jeden tag um sie kümmern so
fühlt es sich für mich an
gut dass power seine kinder im griff hat
der vorletzte waggon des zuges ist der
park wenn der letzte ist die politik sie
ist das markenzeichen des zuges der
comedian ist ein produkt seiner zeit von
den 1930 er bis in die 50er jahre war
stromlinienförmiges design total
angesagt solche waggons findet man
nirgends mehr deshalb reisen leute aus
aller welt an nur um einmal drin zu
sitzen
das günstigste ticket von kuba nach
toronto kostet um die 500 euro
eine luxusreise mit doppelzimmer im
prestige waggon kostet etwa 5000 euro
willkommen in der sky lounge ihr bier
super ich bezahle mit einem 10 dollar
schein auf dem der kamelien drauf
wussten sie dass crew ich hatte keine
ahnung
warum fahren sie mit dem comedian
bitte danke
es ist toll das ist hier kein internet
gibt ich bin vier tage lang für
niemanden zu erreichen
ein bisschen wie urlaub vom alltag
[Musik]
außerdem reist man 70 80 jahre in die
vergangenheit
so ist man früher gereist und es
funktioniert heute nach die technik ist
noch immer up to date
nächster halt ist der jasper national
park teil des unesco welterbes es gibt
immer etwas zu tun ob regen oder sonne
putzen sie immer die fenster wenn der
zug hier hält
teddy wilson packt mit an er sorgt dafür
dass die fenster des comedians
streifenfrei glänzen
[Applaus]
der canadien hat die continentale
wasserscheide überquert und die rockies
überwunden der legendäre zug nimmt fahrt
auf als ich heute aufgewacht bin waren
wir schon in der prärie von saskatchewan
flaches land und weizenfelder so weit
das auge reicht weizen saskatchewan und
die eisenbahn gehören zusammen in jedem
ort an den gleisen gibt es ein silo aus
dem weizen in güterwaggons geschüttelt
diese schienen haben das kechika an
nachhaltig geprägt
ende des 19 jahrhunderts kommen die
ersten siedler in diese gegend und
lassen sich in der prärie nieder
[Musik]
in saskatchewan spürt man den einfluss
der eisenbahn auf kanada besonders
deutlich auf beiden seiten der bahnlinie
entstanden siedlungen und es wurde
handel betrieben
in dieser winzigen küche werden täglich
140 mahlzeiten zubereitet die arbeiten
von 36 bis 22
hier geht es manchmal recht rund das ist
eine ganz schöne herausforderung
haben sie sich schon mal verbrannt nein
einmal wäre ich fast auf den ofen
gefallen zum glück gibt es diese stange
diese stopper verhindern dass töpfe und
pfannen runter wolfen
aber man kann sich auch daran festhalten
man steigert
sowohl für köche wie auch passagiere ist
es angenehmer wenn der züge ruhig dahin
wollte
jeder radsatz hat zwei stahlräder die
starr mit der radsatzwelle verbunden
sind die lauffläche des rades ist schräg
die schiene abgerundet und nach innen
geneigt zwischen rad und schiene fast
höchstens eine 2 cent münze die weniger
reibung zwischen ihnen ist desto ruhiger
laufen die räder der spur kranz an der
innenseite des rades berührt die
schienen bei normaler fahrt nie er dient
nur dazu entgleisungen zu verhindern
vor jeder fahrt prüft an wartungsteam in
kuba die lauffläche einer rede
als erstes prüft das wartungsteam jeden
radsatz aufstellen die verschließen oder
abgefahren sind
sie entstehen wenn der zug stark bremst
und die räder blockieren
wenn es zu viele soll herstellen gibt
wird die fahrt holprig
dann müssen die radsätze zur wartung wo
sie abgedreht werden
diese maschine entfernt
die räder werden in die spezielle
drehmaschine eingespannt und flach
stellen sogenannte abflachen an den rat
laufflächen entfernt
jedes rad mit einer flach stelle wird
abgedreht
ein radsatz das canadian kann bis zu
vier mal erneuert werden er hält
gewöhnlich für etwa ein jahr das sind
eine menge umdrehungen
welcher teil dieser reise ist besonders
häufig
in der prärie geht es immer geradeaus
der comedien fährt vollgas
in den bergen oder am fluss fahren wir
langsam
bin ich ja genau richtig gekommen
perfektes timing
so sind die fußleisten
ich stelle die füße drunter und sie
nicht zurück
so
hat die schuhe jeder hat hier seine
tricks man muss sich gut festhalten
wenn man etwas mit dem messer schneidet
muss man sicher stehen sonst ist der
finger
man kennt man die bewegungen des zügig
und gut dass man sie fast voraus ahnen
kann
wie oft stoßen sie hier drin zusammen
hofft aber wir sind trotzdem noch freude
der canadian ist die ganze nacht durch
die prärie gerollt jetzt nähert er sich
winnipeg manitoba
etwa die hälfte der strecke liegt hinter
kanada ist ein wahnsinnig großes land
der comedien hat es mehr als 2.400 x
durchquert und dabei 97 millionen
kilometer zurückgelegt
das geheimnis seiner langen lebensdauer
findet sich hier im verwaltungszentrum
in montreal
die besten mechatroniker des landes
hegen und pflegen diesellokomotiven sie
werden jede woche gewartet bei dieser
f40 wird die elektronik geprüft das wird
zweimal pro jahr gemacht sie überprüfen
den motor die elektrik die
kommunikationssysteme die
windschutzscheiben und die sicherheits
auf
wie sich herausstellt ist diese lockt
gerade rechtzeitig gekommen
ein mechaniker der den riesigen v16
motor inspiziert findet eine
schwachstelle beim motor ist öl
ausgelaufen
deshalb müssen wir ihn überprüfen
damit die mechaniker das problem beheben
können müssen 215 tonnen kräne den motor
aus der lok geben wir stellen ihn neben
die lok dann fangen wir an zu suchen wo
das öl austritt
es kann tage dauern bis das leck
gefunden ist
ingenieur maxime la péri hilft den
arbeitern die undichte stelle zu finden
wir schauen noch stellen an denen zb
eine dichtung fehlt oder die
versiegelung beschädigt ist
information
sie messen den spalt zwischen
kurbelwelle und gehäuse wenn der spalt
zu groß ist kann öl austreten mit den
messungen wollen sie sicherstellen dass
der motor tadellos läuft
nach 24 stunden haben sabri und sein
team die ursache gefunden ein ablauf ist
verstopft deswegen entweicht öl aus dem
motor das problem wird behoben und die
lok kann zurück aufs gleis
passagiere wir müssen immer in tip top
zustand sein es darf keine verzögerungen
aufgrund schadhafter mechanik geben
der aufmerksamkeit dieser männer ist es
zu verdanken dass der zug nicht auf
freier strecke liegen bleibt
jetzt geht es durch einen teil von
manitoba in dem es weite flusstäler und
breite schluchten gibt um diese
schluchten zu überqueren wurde bock
brücken gebaut
diese ist fast 500 meter lang über 30
meter hoch und ruth auf kräftigen
stahlträgern
alles klar bei ihnen
zugführer chris nato hat in seiner zeit
im canadian alle brücken tausend mal
überquert doch sie faszinieren ihn immer
wieder aufs neue
ich war auch in meiner freizeit gerne
mit dem zug
zu sieht man erst was das land alles zu
bieten
zu reisen ist eine völlig andere
erfahrung
aber wenn man arbeiten muss sieht man
eher selten aus dem fenster wenn doch
mal zeit ist kann ich das richtig
genießen
wir leben hier im schönsten land der
welt
medien wird service groß geschrieben
beim essen wie auch in den schlaf
abteilen was erwarten passagiere von
ihrem bett
sie sind froh wenn sie abends einfach
rein fallen können es sollte aber frisch
gemacht sein
jeder gleisabschnitt hat seinen eigenen
rhythmus
wenn ich morgens aufwache bei sich
sofort ob wir im zeitplan liegen ohne
aus dem fenster zu sehen in den rockies
oder im fraser canyon rechts der zug
durch die links und rechtskurven
in der prärie rumpelt und rattert es
alles verrutscht
wenn sie das ohne geschaukelt tun fühlt
dass sich da nicht komisch an
zu hause mache ich keine betten ich
putze auch keine fenster ich habe meiner
frau gesagt dass ich hier im zug holen
schaufel
das glaubt sie ihnen bis jetzt schon
die hälfte der strecke ist geschafft
gleich fährt der kamelien in winnipeg
ein
der zug bremst ab gerade im bewohnten
gebieten ist es wichtig dass die bremsen
zu 100 prozent funktionieren
darum werden sie in jedem bahnhof
inspiziert die druckluft im bremssystem
muss bis zu den hinteren rädern am
letzten waggon kommen weshalb in
montreal regelmäßig luft leitungen und
ventile überprüft werden ich überprüfe
mit hilfe des hebels ob die steuerung
der bremsen funktioniert
drückt man den hebel einmal nach oben
dann bremst er zugleich das ist die
erste stellung
[Musik]
die robuste druckluft bremse ist ein
markenzeichen der er 40 lockt
sie in und auswendig
die lokomotive hat einen kompressor der
luft in diese behälter kommt mit einem
hebel kann der lokführer situierte viel
druck läuft in die bremszylinder
begleitet wird diese sind über eine
leitung mit einander verbunden sie
bremsen alle auf einmal
es dauert lange bis ein zug zum
stillstand kommt das hat allerdings
nichts mit dem gewicht zu tun
es liegt nicht am gewicht sondern an der
reibung zwischen reedern und schiene
züge haben stahl einer und fahren auf
stahlschienen da ist die reibung nicht
so stark wie bei gummireifen auf
die bremskraft ist also geringer weil
beide teile aus stahl hat
in extremsituationen muss der lokführer
stark bremsen
ziehen wir die notbremse
bei einer notbremsung wird soviel
druckluft wie möglich ins bremssystem
geleitet
das reicht nicht immer gratis
bei der einfahrt in winnipeg
funktionieren die bremsen perfekt
der flug hat 90 minuten aufenthalt die
vorräte werden aufgefüllt und die crew
gewechselt zugführer chris nador
übergibt an seinen kollegin sanierung
alle sind brav du bist dran danke gute
fahrt
der zug hat eine frische tun und neue
passagiere die fahrt kann weitergehen
[Musik]
vorsicht an den türen winnipeg danke für
alles
achtung zu besatzung die türen schließen
[Musik]
und weiter geht's durch kanadas
vielseitige landschaft in zwei tagen
wird der canadian in toronto sein
am dritten morgen sieht die landschaft
wieder völlig anders aus es geht durch
die provinz ontario vor einer stunde hat
der comedian den so lookout passiert der
nächste halt ist saberi
unter den schienen liegt der geologische
kern des nordamerikanischen kontinent
diese gegend ist sumpfiges und
bewaldetes tiefland
das sind denkbar schlechte
voraussetzungen für den bau einer
eisenbahnstrecke
unter dem sumpf land befindet sich der
kanadische schild
einer der härtesten fels böden der erde
um die gleise zu verlegen mussten die
arbeiter trockene erde in gräben
schütten und unebene stellen mit holz
auslegen
gestern konnten sie mit tonnenweise
steine und kies das gleisbett bauen
[Musik]
diese gegend ist extrem dünn besiedelt
für die menschen hier ist der canadian
das fenster zur welt
die eisenbahn ist bis heute eine
lebensader für die menschen hier im
winter sind die straßen gefroren
deswegen kann man sie leichter passieren
sommer sind die kleinen dörfer oft
komplett von der außenwelt abgeschnitten
hier in collins wohnen etwa 30 menschen
es gibt keine zufahrtsstraße
im notfall muss der hubschrauber kommen
er will mitfahren wir kümmern uns um
sein gepäck ich mache ihm die tür auf
wir versorgen die leute hier sie haben
erst seit kurzem strom
wir haben zwei stunden verspätung aber
damit können wir leben wir halten noch
ein paar mal vielleicht holen wir die
zeit nach auf
aber das klappt nur wenn kein passagier
zu spät kommt ein zu spät komme aber wir
warten auf sie wenn wir in den bahnhof
einfahren hupen wer dann kommen sie aus
allen richtungen angelaufen wir nennen
sie marathonläufer
hoch mit der junge mann warum so spät
es hieß ihr hättet verspätung stimmt
kommt noch jemand
gut ich bin gleich bei ihnen
dieser zug sichert ihre grundversorgung
er bringt sie zum einkaufen nach
armstrong er liefert ihnen alle
möglichen sachen baumaterial quads
kühlschränke
hamster meerschweinchen hunde wir haben
schon viel eher lustige dinge
transportiert
die fahrt mit dem canadian würden nie
langweilig leute fahren zum einkaufen in
die nächste stadt lassen sich an ihren
jagdhütten absetzen und manchmal werden
sogar selbe transportiert
und heute abend gibt es eine kanadische
spezialität
wie viele einer
ratio hat bei seiner arbeit im canadian
schon viel erlebt meistens gut ist
meistens
einmal ist ein voll beladener holz
laster mit anhänger in dem zug gekracht
wir sind so um die 120 kilometer pro
stunde gefahren
der lokführer hat den laster gesehen und
eine vollbremsung hingelegt
der zug hat in 13 sekunden von 120 auf
null abgebremst
allerdings sind bei der aktion 14
waggons entgleisten
im zug gab es keinen einzigen verletzten
nicht schlecht für eine entgleisung
ganz richtig es ist mittags passiert
viele leute waren im speisewagen wir
mussten den ganzen passagier wagen
evakuieren die feuerwehr war schnell da
niemand hat viel geredet alle haben
mitgeholfen
die feuerwehr konnte alle passagiere aus
den waggons befreit wenn so etwas noch
einmal passieren sollte weiß ich meine
passagiere in den besten händen
wenn man nach so einem vorfall mit dem
lokführer spricht hört man wie seine
stimme zittert
das ist normal in so einer situation das
nimmt einen natürlich mit
solche situationen sind sehr unangenehm
man wird schnell von seinen gefühlen
übermannt
muss man sich zusammenreißen denn
schließlich brauchen die passagiere
unsere hilfe
der comedian hat auf seiner reise einmal
quer durch kanada fast 4000 kilometer
zurückgelegt langsam aber sicher nähert
er sich dem zielbahnhof roland morgen
nummer vier und satz weiter morgen in
und harry es ist unglaublich wie
riesengroß diese provinz ist
gleich sind wir in toronto der größten
stadt kanadas die meisten bewohner der
provinz saverio leben hier in der
bevölkerungsreichsten region des landes
[Musik]
inzwischen bin ich ein echter profi ich
schlafe tief und fest wie im eigenen
bett wenn ich wieder zu hause bin werde
ich das geschaukel bestimmt vermissen
mein körper hat sich daran gewöhnt
schlafen ist also kein problem aber wie
sieht es mit der standfestigkeit aus sie
arbeiten im service und bedienen im
speisewagen
verteilen sie die gläser gleichmäßig auf
dem tablett und
was das laufen betrifft dazu gruppe
deshalb muss man breitbeinig laufen
gehen sie etwas in die knie um die
bewegungen des zuges aufzufangen
1 mit dem zug genau das ist auch mein
erster kellner job
der nächste muss nicht ganz so wackeln
wünschen sie mehr glück sie machen das
schon
möchte jemand wasser
man muss das glas vorsichtig vom tablett
nehmen weil sich der zug bewegt
wie stelle ich mich an
mögen sie ruhig weiter
das müssen sie sich teilen
[Applaus]
doch jemand wasser
die reise neigt sich ihrem ende entgegen
eine wirklich einmalige erfahrung
immer wenn ich morgens aufgewacht bin
hatte ich das gefühl in einem anderen
land zu sein
das habe ich zwar erwartet aber es mit
eigenen augen zu sehen ist etwas ganz
anderes
außerdem habe ich miterlebt wie diese
bahnstrecke und dieser zug die kleinen
abgeschiedenen dörfern ganz land
verbinden
der canadien ist lebenswichtig für die
menschen
diese gleise halbe kanada geformt
es war einfach toll
der comedien der letzte stromlinien zug
nordamerikas hat wieder einmal 4500
kilometer quer durch kanada zurückgelegt
in weniger als zwölf stunden macht
erklärt und fährt zurück an die
westküste
die legende rollt weiter
[Musik]